oklahoma state legislature has approved
a bill to make abortion a felony in that
state
now if it becomes law doctors who
perform abortions could face up to 10
years in prison and a 100 thousand
dollar fine this is one of a series of
anti-abortion measures that would take
effect around the country if the supreme
court allows them to janet chamberlain
is in oklahoma city with more on this
story janet good morning to you
gail good morning to you oklahoma's
abortion clinics have been caring for
women
from both oklahoma and texas since last
september that's when texas enacted its
own sweeping abortion law and planned
parenthood here in oklahoma says
patients from texas have increased 800
percent since that time now women from
both states may have to travel hundreds
of miles just for basic reproductive
care
keep your bands off our bodies
protesters outside the oklahoma capitol
tuesday it is a dark day in oklahoma
after the republican-controlled house
passed a law banning abortions in the
state resoundly 70 to 14. if you want to
get elected you want to be pro-life
that's the reality in this state
oklahoma's bill is the latest in a
series of anti-abortion laws passed by
republican-led state governments
including one in mississippi currently
before the supreme court if upheld it
would overturn roe v wade right now 21
states have laws on the books that would
ban most abortions if roe is overturned
five others would likely follow suit
these laws are doing exactly what
they've been designed to do right to
make abortion providers fearful rebecca
tong is the co-executive director of
trust women which runs one of oklahoma's
four remaining abortion clinics what i'm
scared of is
that people will not be able to make a
decision that fits their life and it
will change the course and direction of
their life because of it
eight more anti-abortion bills are
currently making their way through the
oklahoma legislature and the governor
kevin stitt says he is prepared to sign
all of them
nate back to you
janet thank you